la codah ce la cour d'assises des
bouches du rhône a condamné à mort
christian ranucci pour avoir enlevé et
assassiné de quinze coups de couteau une
petite fille maria dolorès rambla notre
envoyé spécial à aix pour le faire
l'homme est étrangement seul lorsque
debout entre deux gardes qui guette la
défaillance ou pire l'incident lorsqu'il
entend les mots la cour et les jurés
vous condamne à la peine de mort le mot
mort semble se répéter dans la salle
dans les couloirs
dehors sur le perron où les gens
attendent christian ranucci n'a rien dit
n'a rien fait il est resté de glace
comme figé par l'annoncé d'un avenir si
l'on peut dire qu'il repoussait de toute
certitude depuis de longs mois
pas un cri non plus dans la salle où un
souffle de dignité est finalement passé
un homme s'est effondré un peu plus le
père de l'enfant morte qui a sans doute
réalisé ce soir que rien même ceux qui
le souhaitaient depuis longtemps ne
calmera sa douleur une femme partage
cette souffrance la mère de christian
ranucci eu d'autres victimes
finalement et jurés sont sortis à parent
redescendu dans la foule anonyme dont il
était le symbole conscient j'en suis
sûre d'avoir rempli leur devoir mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu'ils se sentent
soulagés ranucci n'a pas à penser à la
peine de mort lorsqu'il a tué l'enfant
sa tête si elle tombe ne sera pas sans
doute un meilleur exemple
après avoir entendu le premier éco du
couperet ce soir on se sent déchiré par
le meurtre de l'enfant et l'annoncent du
verdict
combien sont tranquilles ceux qui
pensent sincèrement que la peine de mort
et efficace juste exemplaires je les
envie